Today, we're actually gonna talk some pop culture,
so that's like a buoy on top of a raft.
Yeah, you know I happen to like me
just a little bit of pop culture,
and there is a lot goin' on, Drew.
Well, there's a latest story,
conscious uncoupling,
thank you Gwyneth Paltrow for that
ever so useful euphemism.
People reports that Ben Affleck and Ana de Armas
have split after almost a year of dating.
And I guess Ben put this cardboard cutout of her,
and kicked it to the curb and now--
Like an actual life-size cardboard cutout
being put in the trash.
That is very unique to have
a cardboard cutout of your partner.
What do ya think, Ross?
Well, why do you have to put
the whole cardboard cutout out front?
You know, it's always so confusing.
The green bin's for recycling.
Which one's for the ex?
That seems a little hardcore,
but it does beg the question,
what do you do when you break up with somebody
and you have a bunch of their stuff?
Maybe not a cardboard cutout, but their stuff.
Do you give it back to them?
Do you treat it nicely?
What do you do?
I used to save all these mementos in boxes,
and then all the relationship would end up
like boxes in my closet.
And I don't know where any of it is now.
I've lost it all.
Are you friends with an ex, are you friendly?
Yeah, totally.
Yeah, me too.
A lot of people are not capable of that.
You know, I had to learn if your current person
isn't okay with it,
like you don't need to stand on ceremony probably
and be like, this is who I am.
I'm friends with my exes.
You're gonna have to gauge it from person to person,
but I like things to be amicable.
There was something good there.
I think once you love somebody,
if you're in love with somebody once,
you should love them forever in any way that you can.
Keep that cardboard cutout!
Well, let's not go that far, dear.
We do have to move on.
All right, you're next.
And someone who knows a lot about movin' on,
breakups, and makeups
is everyone's favorite, Carrie Bradshaw.
And Drew, I can't wait for Sarah Jessica Parker's
"Sex and the City" return.
It's coming soon, everybody.
Remember, we announced just a couple of weeks ago.
Well in the meantime, The Daily Mail says SJP
has been super busy at her other job
slinging slingbacks.
She has two SJP Collection stores right here in the city,
and she actually goes to work.
You guys, she goes to the shoe store
and personally helps customers.
There she is right there.
You go in there like, I need a size,
do you have a size 10 in these, SJ?
And she goes and gets them for you.
And I wonder if she's kickin' it
like assistant manager style,
and she has that keychain around her, you know what I mean?
I love the foot measuring thing, too.
I kinda want one of those in my house for the kids,
because their feet are always ever-changing.
And fun fact, her flagship store
is the old Manolo Blahnik store
where Carrie Bradshaw used to shop!
It's one of those moments,
full circle, thank you for that.
I also think when you have a brand,
a lot of things are direct to consumer
and you can't reach the people.
And I think the fact that she has a brick and mortar
and can engage with customers
is kind of a dream come true for people.
When you make things, you do wanna share them
and express, so I'm glad to see her making the most of this.
Well you have like flower products.
You gonna be like in the aisle at the store?
Oh, I'd love to be.
I know!
You would totally love that.
Oh my gosh, I would be SJP-ing out, completely.
Well, you know where I'll be later today.
I'll be at that store.
Is she here?
By the way, I totally just thought like, yeah okay.
Okay, maybe one day.
Well, the home of Carrie Bradshaw
and "Sex and the City" themselves, HBO Max
has even more stores, and gifts in store for us, oopsy.
And including a "Friends" reunion!
It's happening!
People reports that Lisa Kudrow says
she's already shot scenes for the special,
and it will be the first time
the gang's back together in one place,
and they shoot in front
of a live studio audience this spring.
Ross, have you seen "Friends" once, twice, or 1,000 times?
I have seen, I've seen all of "Friends"
and I missed 'em.
I mean, we've been on a break.
(Ross giggles)
Get it?
That's a "Friends" reference, everybody.
I'm wondering, do Ross and Rachel have kids?
Is Central Perk still open?
How's the monkey?
I have so many questions.
Marcel!
Marcel.
Yeah, you're a fan, I can tell.
I am.
Yeah.
And the HBO Max hits keep coming, Drew.
We got one more.
Variety reports they've just ordered
an eight episode drama called "Julia"
all about the life and career
of someone you're obsessed with, Julia Child, mm-hmm.
I cannot handle how excited I am for this.
Well you know, remember that movie "Julie & Julia?"
My favorite movie ever!
It's so great, and it was one of those movies I watched
and I thought, I had no idea
how fascinating Julia Child was.
When I was a kid, she was just the woman, oh, like that.
Oh!
But there wouldn't be food television if it wasn't,
I can't do Julia Child.
No, mine sounded like Mrs. Doubtfire just a little bit.
I know!
There would not be food television, I don't believe,
if it wasn't for Julia Child.
She kicked off a new genre!
She did, and this show sounds like it's gonna be amazing.
Sarah Lancashire will play Julia,
and the cast includes David Hyde Pierce,
Isabella Rossellini, and Bebe Neuwirth
who is iconic.
We don't know when it's gonna be released yet,
but I know you're gonna be watching it.
Well, it can't come soon enough.
I need this in my life,
and she was just such a genius.
She was groundbreaking, she was funny.
I loved her, her food was exceptional
and she taught us all these tricks,
and made us all home cooks.
And speaking of food, tricks, and geniusness,
we've been obsessed with a particular brand
of food innovation that you can only find
on TikTok, of course.
So, today if you're someone who loves your sandwiches
hot and toasty, we're about to blow your mind.
That's right.
I'm so excited about this.
I know, okay I'm gonna bring in
lifestyle expert Michelle Park,
and hello Michelle!
Hi!
Hi guys!
(audience applauds)
I'm so excited that you're here, and guess what?
We are gonna go to commercial break,
and when we come back, everybody stay around
because Michelle, you're gonna teach us a toaster hack
that's gonna change our lives?
Yeah, I mean I don't think Julia Child
would approve of this, but I approve, it's really fun.
I, I'm just really excited to learn it.
(upbeat music)